posing for the traditional family photo
the top diplomats of the G7 still firmly
committed to supporting Ukraine in its
war with Russia they agreed to keep
sanctions in place and to stop Moscow
from trying to get weapons from third
countries after accusations North Korea
is already supplying them and fears that
China might start we will family reject
any unilateral attempts to change the
status quo by force or Russia's relation
against Ukraine as well as its threat of
use of nuclear weapons the foreign
ministers criticized Russia's decision
to station tactical nuclear weapons in
Belarus as the only country in the world
to be attacked with atomic bombs Japan
has condemned Russia's repeated nuclear
rhetoric and its G7 presidency
culminates with the leaders Summit next
month in Hiroshima the location of the
first nuclear attack the foreign
ministers also reaffirmed their
commitment to a free and open
indo-pacific seen as a pushback against
China's growing power and influence in
the region and an answer to the
continuing Threat by Beijing against the
island of Taiwan but the ministers have
also been dealing with the growing
crisis in Sudan with U.S Secretary of
State Anthony blinken calling for an
immediate ceasefire also
probably help you again across all of
our partners on the need for an
immediate ceasefire and a return to
talks talks that were very promising in
putting Sudan on the path to a full
transition to civilian LED government
the fighting in Sudan will likely
continue to feature prominently in
discussions until this meeting ends on
Tuesday Rob McBride Al Jazeera
karawizawa Japan